es una pérdida de 500 mil automóviles y
gigante francés renaud reducirá su
producción medio millón de vehículos no
saldrán a la venta más del doble de lo
que habían predicho hace un mes la
industria automotriz en todo el mundo ha
estado luchando ante la escasez de
semiconductores un componente esencial
lo que está provocando el aumento de los
precios de los vehículos
en esta fábrica de reno se detuvo la
producción durante dos semanas y en esta
planta en el este de francia también se
ha paralizado la actividad de tensión ha
pasado una semana y es frustrante
moralmente es difícil para los empleados
saber que no podemos fabricar porque no
tenemos las piezas allí se fabrican
vehículos comerciales pero en los
últimos cinco días 2000 empleados han
sido despedidos
el primero el cover y ahora los
componentes que escasean no ha sido
fácil el resurgimiento de la pandemia en
asia donde se producen los
semiconductores es lo que está causando
el déficit para algunos sindicatos
traslada la producción a francia podría
resolver el problema o no de composición
tenemos algunas ideas tenemos programada
una reunión para la semana que viene
para proponer la fabricación de
semiconductores en francia
sugerimos que se haga cerca de nuestras
fábricas para que podamos arreglar
nuestra cadena de suministro
reno registró una pérdida del 20% en
ventas en su tercer trimestre además sus
ingresos cayeron a poco menos de nueve
mil millones de euros un 13% menos que
en 2020 durante el mismo período